what are like some of your least
favorite tropes you've seen in hentai
manga than or in in in your field or
maybe like a trope you would never
personally use yeah oh
i don't know like
walking into like a girl bathing
slipping and then like oh
catching yourself by the boobies
so basically every scene into lover
the entirety of talking that goes beyond
just like hentai manga that's just like
yeah
in general right yeah
it does get old very fast but it's a
classic though it's a classic but it's
like there are i feel there are
especially some like uh you know h manga
that it's just like
every chance they can get it's like so
we have this new girl character yeah how
do we introduce her to the audience
they better be stinky because they're
going in the bars right now
yeah
how much research you have to do for
when you work on something i just have
to say research because it is research
man
it's the only guy i could talk to and
ask if it's actually research because it
is research yeah like the more you do
the better because like
they are
there's so much work out there that
there's always some kind of new way of
showing like a scene like a new angle or
a
a new device of like you know showing uh
whatever yeah yeah yeah that you know
you could always incorporate into your
work so like you know you should always
read other people's stuff um i mean yeah
porn makes like marvel's output look
like nothing yeah there's so much out
there it seems it's insane especially
especially the dojin scene in japan it's
like crazy
every time yeah why are there so many
transformer ones
i don't know
transformer which i don't know i have
noticed that actually
every time i've gone to the stores
there's like 15 optimus prime getting
boned people yeah i find transformers
sexy i don't know i mean
bumblebee does pee on something yeah
i guess that's maybe fuel
yeah i've noticed transfo there's a lot
of transformers and sailor moon like
sailor moon makes sense
sailor moon makes more sense yeah but
you find people doing sailor moon these
days though i don't know i still find a
lot of like i don't know if they knew
necessarily the most popular ones now
like ones to make those well there's
always the you know people who do the
newest thing
yeah uh
fate is always popular
um one that's any of the idols
idolmaster yeah one that's big right now
is like blue archive stuff oh yeah that
one there's a lot of that can you
explain to me
how the dojin like rules or laws work in
japan because okay everyone knows that
japanese copyright laws are like
non-existent
you literally you know there's no fair
use or anything like that but it seems
to be like doujins have been like all
right we'll let you we'll let you slide
like what's there's an honor code
basically okay okay where if the um
original copyright holder says no
doujins you shouldn't do indulgence okay
they don't say anything it's [ __ ]
they don't say anything it's fair game
okay oh wow so they kind of just like
turn the blind eye or something or yeah
basically i mean like
um
recently you know there's been um
yeah yeah and they said no doujins
don't do it oh wow okay almost feels
like you're a waste not too though yeah
you think that's like the one series as
well yeah like that's like waifu's
galore right for a lot of the fans so
you'd think there'd be like a massive
market well you know it's based on like
real life voices oh yeah you know it's
kind of like you know you don't want it
i guess like weird politics coming out
right
my baby i don't want to see my baby kind
of like yeah
better stick to apes right yeah
how much of your work goes into
preparing for basically comic cat
because like like and how much is it
just in general trying to appeal to like
you know just the mass audience and you
know putting your work online nowadays
well
back when you know there was comiket
um
you know twice a year
that's like the main bread and butter of
like your dodging work right
so you know two of these and then
that was pretty much like a few years
ago
moderately successful dojin artist then
come make it twice a year you could live
off of it right i am okay wow you know
so people usually do that and then like
other dojin events on the side or
like magazine work on the side yeah
how hard is it to get like a booth or a
table or comic yeah like what's the
process of that
by the way it's like japanese comic con
it's massive comic market very
complicated
very huge
it's like what like
300 400 000 people or something that's
insane it's the biggest convention right
by far it's i think it's one of the
biggest conventions in the world yeah
and it's all donation yeah it's it's all
donations
it's old ocean yeah it's it's not like
it's not all like hentai it's like every
kind of yeah
just means like you know self-published
self-published stuff yeah yeah so like a
lot of like i learned that from trash
takes as well yeah because so there's
like there's like entire sections of
comic con where it's just like the
non-errors yeah it's like just like
novels or like
music or
that can attract that many people yeah
yeah i feel like there's a convention
like that in the us or the uk i don't
think it would be nearly as big well
because like it's anime is just a lot
less accessible over there you know like
you know if if they want the same kind
of anime convention experience here in
japan you just go to akihabara yeah
right it's it's a lot so i can
understand why
there is this market for this here um
but it seems like you know like like you
said a lot of livelihoods depend on
the two main comikets right um so like
how hard is it to get a booth there or
to like to be a part of that event like
if you're
established then you get a cup i think
you get priority seating
before and you've been consistently like
putting stuff out yeah they'll look
favorably on you and give you a space
mutually
but if you're new then it's it's like a
nice thrill basically sometimes you have
to
no i mean
it really is pretty random oh okay wow
yeah it's gotcha it's got like
it's like ticketed events in japan just
lottery right yeah so it's like
completely luck which sucks because it's
like well i was here first can i have a
ticket please yeah you'd think it's like
first come first serve right but yeah
yeah because how did you get your first
booth in comic yet i just applied you
just supplied yeah
and then he rolled
and he wrote the ssr or the ssr dude so
if you're like not established at all
and you go to communicate right how are
you getting people to come stop by the
booth or
check it out
if people walk by and you're like hey
take a look at my stuff and then that's
how you have to do it but there's i
think there's also like a lot of comic
cake goers who are just there to
purely consume all the new [ __ ] yeah and
they're kind of like there to like as
like scouts almost to be like you know
how many tables are we talking how many
sellers like i have no idea thousands
oh my god yes it feels like if you're if
you haven't made a name for yourself how
on earth would you stand out if there's
thousands of people if you're seeing
like a picture of comiket it's like you
get
it's like a sea of like you know yeah
people you get drowned out easily so
it's just like you have to you know hope
someone walks by and you know takes a
look at your stuff it's literally like
busking on the street right it's just
like you just have to hope
that you're drawing enough that you just
have to hope you're drawing enough
attention where someone will stop to
like listen nowadays you know there's
twitter and other like
online pheasants before you do comic con
yeah yeah how important is that as an
aero
artist
old school so like it doesn't matter
yeah yeah yeah cause i i started before
twitter right so yeah i guess you were
already established before the social
media thing right yeah nowadays if
you're starting it's it's definitely
important to have like some kind of
online presence and i feel that like
just you know i think in especially on
twitter like that community as well as
like really supportive of other artists
like i see like dojo notice i follow on
twitter retweeting other dojin yeah all
the time
i don't retweet any of it mind you i
only like it
it just appears on your timeline that's
all yeah i think i followed like two
dozen artists or something yeah um
like at the start and then like just by
following one or two my entire timeline
was filled yeah with hentai because they
they're constantly retweeting each
other's
you know your twitter is like a cesspool
but like you don't really see it if
you're doing dojin yeah well that's why
half the people are full on twitter are
just dojon artists
because i don't want to see that other
[ __ ] horrid cesspool on twitter yeah
it's like the pornhub comments section
right which is like the most wholesome
comment section you will find on the
internet it's like yes king thank you
for your importance i appreciate it w
[Laughter]
yeah like i guess have you um
have you ever thought about having like
putting more effort into having like a
more like bigger online presence and
maybe like growing your audience there
and getting like an audience that will
you know support the patreon or like
i have a patreon but i'm really bad at
updating it yeah yeah yeah yeah because
i'm just too i'm i'm lazy first of all
but like when i get into like drawing
something like if i start working on a
project and i'm too focused on it to do
anything else yeah yeah yeah so like
updating a weekly thing is like oh god i
have to spend hours like doing that yeah
yeah yeah yeah what about like stuff
like uh like do you have like a skip or
anything like no not at the moment
obviously
but then it's like more stuff i have to
say oh yeah that's true yeah that's true
do you want to explain what scab is skep
is basically like it's it's like fiverr
where you can like commission artists to
draw whatever it is you want and like i
think in like recent times skep has like
really gotten massive overseas just
because like a lot of like independent v
tubers you know especially like higher
japanese artists because you know it's
like
i'm an anime you know i'm a virtual
anime girl who am i gonna get to draw a
virtual enemy girl probably an anime
artist with an anime style right so
that's like really blown up recently and
like i know like a lot of like
independent artists and like doujin
artists like live purely off of skip
commissions right like
some artists make blink bank off skip
yeah
yeah i mean and there's a lot of porn on
scam
like a lot of porn there is it's like an
insane amount of porn on screen it's a
lot of porn while the porn that can be
commissioned by very very talented
artists exactly like the
the disparity between the work you see
on fiverr and the workers in your skep
is like night and day
not even a comparison yeah it's crazy
how good yeah if you want to go get a
commission good arts uh good artists uh
go on skip and like skep has like a
feature now where like even if you write
the commission in english it auto
translates to japanese oh it does that
yeah yeah so like a lot of japanese
artists now like you don't have to write
in like broken japanese like the the
auto translation
you don't have to be like that now so
like yeah because like i know a lot of
like my english speaking friends who
don't know a word of japanese so yeah
just commission a bunch of japanese
artists and they get exactly what they
want oh cool yeah yeah so it's really
cool they really like optimize that